hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to my old recording
setup look it's a foam wall and look I'm
in front of my one true love
my computer once again it's been far too
long
no more caps gaming for me but
unfortunately my voice is a little bit
on the out and out my throat feels like
an easy-bake oven it's not going well
for me so I'm going to do something that
I hope is going to be a lot of fun and
I'm going to be photoshopping my fellow
youtubers faces it's probably going to
be very insulting and I already have the
first suggestion I got these from
Facebook but I also want your
suggestions down the road this one is
from Brad Defty he says draw Photoshop
me is the dad from happy wheels and Jack
as the son on the back of the bike and
to save some time I already brought up
our faces because there's only one foot
of Jack that I would ever ever Photoshop
and it's this one that you see in front
of you hopefully because it's the most
amazing photo I've ever seen and then I
have myself which is a generic photo
from way back one so let's get started
shall we
I guess okay here we go anyway if this
goes as well as my transitions I should
have no problem at all
okay so the first thing that's problem
here that anyone would be able to see is
that obviously he's not smiling Jack is
known for his sunny disposition as most
Irish are so we need to turn that frown
upside down somehow good enough for me
I'd and by the way I know that a lot of
people are going to be very upset
because I know that my my photoshopping
technique is only mastered by oh god
it's beautiful already I don't think I
need to make much else change I know
that my Photoshop techniques are not
going to be the best it's going to be
very wishy-washy for me run out so just
ah I didn't copy that to a new layer
hang on one second I forgot again I was
too distracted by how amazing it was all
right
well there we go oh that's little Jackie
boy right there oh he's looking good
how you feeling there jack are you
looking pretty happy there I'm so glad
that you're going to be enjoying this
scenario although you look somehow a lot
older that you did before but that
doesn't matter just bear with it the
pain is not yet over I'm pretty sure
that all of us knew that the majority of
this [ __ ] was going to be done with
the liquify tool and if you don't know
what the liquify tool is well my god
here it is and here we go and I'm going
to be insulting the Irish because I want
to turn turn Jack into a leprechaun cuz
why not
I was supposed to be turning Jack into a
little boy I don't know he turned into
an old leprechaun but it's good enough
for me I'm happy as it is once again I
sound a lot like that saloon order from
Deadwood but that's ok that's what
happens when my voice goes and when I
get back to my recording setup gig all
right
top of the morning to you laddies my
name is jacksepticeye don't mind the
voice change just know that I'm here to
be manipulated by the douchebag known is
markiplier don't worry I'm next Jack I
think I think I've done enough damage to
Jack let's go to me now this is this is
just like my photo booth video but
instead I get to choose exactly how it
goes
I look like Ben Bennett Bennett bunked
benebalm cook lumber blump
Kim flim Bob lamp Canberra Blanche I
think that's definitely it yeah yeah
yeah yeah dick yeah I'm not exactly sure
what I was going for here boy am I glad
I reached it ok now he's just gotta give
the happy wheels in there
I know that we're supposed to be on a
bike but I feel like this is more
appropriate it was going to stand the
test of time just a little bit more oh
by the way all of these will be
available as wallpaper sized things
after I'm done just look for them in the
description it should be there if it's
not just yell at me in the comments
until I put it there
my goodness Jack you've never looked so
good in all your life I can't explain my
feelings towards you right now mostly
because I don't want to look at you but
that's okay I think that represents the
epitome of childhood right here if I had
to bear with this on the back of my neck
for an eternity I wouldn't be much too
happy either
I don't know what the hell's going on
with my hair anyway well if that isn't
just the most horrible thing I've ever
seen in my entire life
well I think we're done here we've done
enough damage I don't know how we could
possibly else do this but there you have
it jack has the Sun and me as the dad
and we're trust us we're on a bike
definitely on a bike oh can I stop
looking at this now all right so this
next one I'm gonna have to go all out
it's by Pedro Moreno who said I should
draw Aaron and Danny as babies fighting
each other so I went ahead and grabbed
some assets that I think I I've got a
plan for this I think I know what I'm
going to do but it's going to take a
long time so just bear with me this
one's going to be very involved I can't
wait
by the way if you haven't googled baby
fighting god damn google that the images
are freaking in a ladder it's all right
so first up is Aaron I found this
picture of them but it's not very clean
so I got a do a bit of cleanup to try to
make I don't know it it popped just a
little bit better it's so hard because
it was literally literally a grab from
like a ninja sex party video from like
the tiniest idiots bit of it so here we
go god
I think that's best I'm going to get out
of that oh no uh-uh
he looks like the Queen from Alice in
Wonderland oh I can't do voices right
now not even a little bit I think that
needs to be pitch black inside his mouth
oh well goddamn if that isn't the
scariest thing I've ever created I'm not
sure what it is but there's Aaron and
now we actually have a handsome face of
Danny to work with with high resolution
on all that jazz let's see how badly we
can screwed up if you ask me Danny is
just a little bit too handsome so we
need to change that a little bit I'm not
sure how I have an idea I don't know why
I want to do this to Danny he's like the
nicest guy ever but here we go I already
established that I'm going to be a bit
of an [ __ ]
in these oh no he's gonna be the one
that got beat up oh that's perfect yes
it was there was absolutely no reason
for me to cut that out
I even messed up my blood but I don't
care it had the desired effect
oh god that's terrifying well I think
Danny's done good job me I really did a
number on him and unfortunately is going
to be turned into a baby now and beaten
up so yay here we go
I don't know about you but I'm pretty
sure this baby means business I wouldn't
want to get in a fight with him I think
Jenny would either oh or Danny is an
unhappy would a baby or Danny like a
fight or two bad cuz I've got another
idea that's probably her that's probably
going to be as horrible as ever because
I found this photo and I loved it to
death
and I want to figure out how they get
Aaron's face onto this baby
well here we go
oh my goodness Oh God Oh
I done had laid eyes ah ha ha ha ha
that is the evilest little baby I've
ever seen oh the nose just fits
perfectly with it I think I've made the
greatest creation ever and I'm not even
done kind of but I love my job
oh man Danny does not look happy about
his title vows but he's got a fight he's
gotta clean his [ __ ] have you know what
I've made you might thinking but we're
not done yet dot either close we gotta
make this look as epic as possible
because come on how many opportunities
do I guess
oh my goodness I think we're just about
done I think I'm done this is like one
of my favorite things I've ever made I'm
so happy this exists either way like I
said you can find these images down in
the description below I'll try to find
some way to link them but oh yeah
Aaron Danny you are so welcome you are
so welcome no thanks are required you
are good in my book okay
this is taking a lot longer than I
thought I did I've been doing this for
like 40 minutes it's cuz I've been
fiddling with it so minutely but I'm
gonna do another one here hopefully in
the future I could do these a bit
quicker cuz I'm not just doing the
phases I'm doing whole scenarios here so
here we go more suggestions yes okay
this one is by far the most genius idea
that I've ever heard in my life
Alexander Webb wants me to make jontron
as every bird from Birdemic and if you
haven't seen Chum Tron's review of
Birdemic you need to see that
immediately and also was this cuz i'm
going to have so much fun with this it's
not even fair yeah
I like to keep them relatively within
the realm of what it could be without
just going to town with the liquefied
school but good god oh man I love it way
too much fun with his age tub oh it's
gonna be a shame because it's gonna be
so small damn it it's gonna be wasted
just because it's gonna be tiny damn it
oh well I guess it's okay Oh works of
art will go unappreciated oh the effort
that I put into making jontron this
beautiful bird oh well it is what it is
what it is oh yeah okay is so terrifying
I don't know what I've done but I've
done something amazing this has to be
the ringleader it just has to be I can't
imagine this being anywhere else right
now oh oh good golly this is not going
well I'm doing everything wrong
welcome to Milkovich is Milkovich show
Milkovich is going to destroy humans at
adult oh the birds
yeah I'm okay with this Oh lost about
there and there we go
Oh God oh man I think I think I'm done I
think I'm done I think three is probably
my limit I mean I did promise I would
make every single one of them it did
worry into John's face here so let me
just add there you go
jontron has every bird from Birdemic
it's most horrible if this was coming to
attack my village I would just give up
god this would not be worth fighting so
to recap we have John promised every
bird from Birdemic we have Danny and
Aaron his babies fighting it trust me
that is arid I stole it directly from
his face it's still him and of course be
a jack as father and son as it should be
so anyway this was a lot of fun but I've
been recording for an hour now I only
got through three I thought I would get
through more but I went really really
involved so I would love to do this
again so if you can help me out
let me know what you figure this if you
want more in the first place and if you
do let me know what do you do where you
want to see me Photoshop what else you
want to see me do and in what crazy
situation you want them to be in because
some of these suggestions and there were
hundreds of them are hilarious so I want
to do more if you want to see more so
thanks again everybody so much for
watching
check out the annotation for more crazy
videos check out the photobooth my video
but a bit loud
check out the photobooth video that I
did of my own face getting warped and
thanks again everybody for watching it's
good to be back in my normal recording
space so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
gonna try that's the way marketing back
way